dogs who ride skateboards cats playing
keyboards dogs that are too cute to
handle as long as the internet has been
around so too has the viral pet video
the first cat video of the modern
Internet is attributed to pajamas and
Nick Drake released in 2005 the very
first cat film ever made however was the
disturbing 1894 short released by Thomas
Edison yes that Thomas Edison in the
fight between cats and dogs canines as a
group outrank cats in terms of most
searches Facebook Likes and total views
but individual cats are significantly
more viral than individual dogs there's
an ethnographic element to what viral
animals we prefer in Uganda chickens and
goats are more prevalent in online memes
than dogs and cats these videos might
not actually be a waste of time
according to one 2015 study people
measured feeling happier and less
anxious after watching videos of cats
and people who reported watching the
most cat videos tended to be more
cooperative friendly and trusting but
who are the most viral pets on the
Internet we looked at Facebook Likes
Instagram followers YouTube video views
and Twitter followers to compile a short
list motto the Box sliding cat is a
sensation on YouTube Lil bub the tongue
drooping feline is a multi-platform hit
with an internet talk show a documentary
and a merch line Mishka the talking dog
reached breakaway internet fame for
being able to say boo the stuffed animal
come to life Pomeranian boasts three
books a product line and an endorsement
deal with Virgin American Airlines and
last but not least grumpy cats grumpy
cat has an endorsement deal with
Friskies a Lifetime movie where she's
voiced by a brie Plaza and earns an
average yearly salary in the low six
figures
yep it's good being instafamous but to
our Viral stars yawn